Beneath The Still Waters of this
Reservoir ancient ruins have been
revealed
the 17th Century Village of West End was
cleared when thrust cross Reservoir was
built in the 60s its remains flooded
but as water levels continue to fall The
Old Village centered around this flax
Mill is visible once more
this was the churchyard wall
the foundations for a house
The Village's main Bridge
this is a feed reservoir for several
others so you'd expect it in hotter
weather to look a little bit drier but
the fact that I'm sitting on a road
that's been submerged for years
indicates not only the impact of the
recent hot weather but of two
consecutive Springs and Summers with
below average rainfall
the environment agency confirmed today
that Reservoir levels are falling across
Yorkshire Central and Southwest England
Thames water which supplies to 15
million customers across London and the
southeast told us if we do not receive a
round or above average rainfall in the
coming months this will increase
pressure and our resources and may
indeed result in the need for more water
saving measures including restrictions
river flows across the country are also
receding all the springs in this Farm
have dried up something that's not
happened in years we've been a lot drier
I've been having to take water out to
the sheep and cattle
um it's it's been a while since I've had
to do that people do need to be more
mindful about how much water they are
using
if they realize you know just sort of
how short we'll get on water they might
need to think twice about washing cars
and how often the water the gardens
today the government convened its second
Cobra meeting this week to look at if
the temperature surge expected early
next week would mean either restrictions
or emergency measures
so level four is obviously assessed
independently and they look at a variety
of impacts but fundamentally the
temperature is is what what determines
it and the longevity of the temperature
so we're looking we think at the mid to
high 30s there's a possibility it may go
higher to that 40 but record
nevertheless Health officials say what's
crucial is for people to be vigilant to
watch out for vulnerable neighbors stay
hydrated and to stay out of the Sun
Sky News